pg
how you doing good we'll jump uh
right in with cameron hey paul
tough loss my man um assuming that you
guys want to run this back next year
what additions or what changes to the
roster would you like to see
none none um
first year together um
you can't even say we want to change our
roster we like what we got
um i mean we've been saying it all years
just chemistry being together
um the more we can be together the
better we will be
um year one it's year one we got a lot
to
reflect on a lot to look at um going
forward and to get better with
a question from the bubble from mark
spears
paul you should talk about the fourth
quarter that's kind of what was blowing
your mind when you
saw that thing um i mean
they made shots they made shots it's
been really the uh
the tale of the series um they've been
making shots playing at a faster pace
um you know and they got free tonight
thought uh jamal got free um
jokic made big plays kept the ball alive
big rebounds
um you know they they they played well
they played well to close the game out
tonight what i mean
how did i feel yeah as they're making
shots
as the fourth quarter was unfolding i'm
sure you're pretty shocked
um i mean
from my perspective just keep fighting
um keep fighting
try to see the ball go down um you know
we kind of got cold in that fourth um
all we could do was fight at that point
we tried to get stops we tried to
you know force them into turnovers um
they did
a great job of playing through that um
they made big plays big shots and uh
you know it just looked like we couldn't
get enough stops that we needed
we'll stay down there and go to dan um
you talk about kind of the second half
and going cold and the frustration from
that
was that compounded by the fact that it
happened
in game six two almost exactly the same
way and it happened again
did that cumulatively just build on you
guys the fact that it happened kind of
three nights in a row
um no i wouldn't say
you know i wouldn't necessarily say that
um
we just we get the same looks we've been
getting the same shots that we've been
getting in the first half of all those
games
we just as as a squad just went cold
and on the other side of that they kept
just running their stuff they kept
running in with pace with speed
um and getting the looks they want to
get um
you know for them they're missing those
shots in the first half
um we're making ours in the first half
um and it's
complete opposite in the second half of
each of those games so
um i don't think the previous games were
wearing on us
again we knew we had to win this it's
game seven
um we just went cold as a team how's
that gonna stay with you
i mean who knows when next season is
gonna start knowing that you guys had
double digit leads three times
well that hurts that hurts it hurts
um it hurts but um
we move on you know again um
year one together first first run um
together of course we wanted to win this
um but we've been very optimistic
um about us being together and and
building something
um going down the road
go to home well um
almost since like you and kawhi teamed
up all anybody wanted to talk about was
how the lakers and clippers were the two
title favorites and
it almost happened at any point though
did you guys feel like
you know maybe this was going to happen
or felt the pressure to make that happen
and also how would you assess your first
season with kawhi
uh i mean it was great a great first
season with kauai
you know still learning figuring each
other out
but i thought we had a great year
playing off each other
we can only improve off that um
but i mean it's pressure you want this
pressure you want you
you want that pressure um first time
i've been on the team and been
considered
uh and not could not be considered the
underdog
so it was different but um you want that
pressure
as a competitor as a guy that want to
compete you want that pressure
uh fact of the matter is we
we we didn't make it to where we wanted
to get to um
tip our hats off to denver they played
great and uh again
all we got to do is look forward to the
next one
question from jonathan down in the
bubble in the nba level so as a journey
comes to an end we're asking players to
give us their last work on the nba
bombing experience
um not really sure
next question we'll go to miriam
hey paul um thanks for all your help
this year um
wanted to lou mentioned that that you
guys had a quick conversation as a team
um kind of looking forward can you talk
about that like what do you guys tell
each other
after this experience the after the game
yeah um i mean we we just you know
stayed positive about it
you know if we stay positive about it
again we tipped our
our hats off to the opponents um they
played good down the stretch
um but you know it hurt as as a group
um you know it's not the the outcome
that we wanted
um but we stayed together regardless
uh we talked it out we stayed together
in the locker room
um and again we uh
kind of knew what this was um
it's a team that's that's you know we're
looking for the long run
and um keep saying it all we got from
here
is to be positive going down for going
forward on what we can be and
um you know the team in the future
that's all we have right now
um and you know we're just positive and
optimistic about it we have time for a
couple more go to andrew
apg lou was saying that you know this
season the
chemistry wasn't able to reach its full
potential you know i'm talking about
changing roles and obviously the long
break off
didn't help i guess what what kept it
you feel like from reaching its full
potential this year and how how would
you like to see that change
uh going into next year um
i think just adversity a lot of
adversity we dealt with
um rightfully so you know guys had to
you know go home for uh you know
rightful reasons um you know and we just
missed
a lot of time being together um with
injuries in the regular season and
inside the bubble
um you know so we we didn't get much
time to be together
um this was the longest stretch i think
that we have played together
but it just wasn't enough and um you
know i think in this series it
showed denver's a team that played been
playing together for a long time
when things got got rough when when you
know
they needed this or needed that they
just know each other
they've been on the stream for so long
and i think it showed
and we'll take one final question from
gary down in the bubble
ever since that july night that
kauai signed and then clippers traded
for youtube
championship talk well expectations just
too high
considering all the new guys all the
guys with learning systems
was just too much but you guys had to
kind of take it on because that was
the expectations uh
yeah i mean again it's it's it's obvious
pressure
um you know to to live up to the title
expectations
um but as a player i mean you want that
like
you know you you want that um again it's
first time i've i've
been in that situation um
where we're expected to win um
you know but you know
it is what it is um it's it's it's no
cop
out um fact of the matter is we didn't
live up to that expectation
uh but i think internally we we we've
always felt
um this is not a championship or bus
year for us uh you know we we can only
get better
the longer we stay together and the more
we're around each other
um the more chemistry for this group the
better
i think that's really the tail of the
tape of the season we just didn't have
enough time together
thanks pete have a good night appreciate
it
it's been you know shocking
uh you said um pandemic
um a legend you know passing away from
you know crazy accident and uh
you know less coming here to uh
like um you know just to play these
games um
it's been heavy uh but
you know i'm happy i'm just telling him
i'm happy that uh you know we got to
play basketball again and
um you know probably kept
a lot of us upbeat there was obviously a
lot of reasons
to beat down things happening in the
world i know this place stopped
there were some questions about whether
or not you guys wanted to keep going
um mentally do you think you guys end up
teaming all in and having everything for
sure
uh yeah everybody wants to play how much
you put on that jersey is
no
it's time to you know
[Music]
uh great the sharks
lost the damage you know last two games
were pretty much
good you know but that's coming in
you know not able to sweat the ball
third on the fourth quarter
and
you know denver did an amazing job you
guys did a great job
the team is playing uh that's a certain
way
um you know trying to get the ball out
of my hands attacking the pain
we got to know what to do
um
next we're going to go to um
hey kawhi um this team that was never
able to reach its full potential how do
you view
this season after people thought you
guys were title contenders and
and what needs to happen what needs to
be added to this team that might be
missing
i don't know right man i'm not gonna say
that
but i would just tell them you know
like i was just saying uh just just
being smarter
just knowing uh that's being up within
them you don't know what to do with
situations when uh
guys are playing in certain ways and um
you know just seeing how we can get some
execution down the stretch guys knowing
exactly where
where they need to be the first time our
situation we can't
fall and hold all right you you know
those are the big
things uh that's what you know
championship teams have um
you know they have like chemistry um
they know exactly what to do
next we'll go to the question in the
bubble
yeah people are going to take over this
team
you know the way it externally how would
you guys
look back and pick over and why
um like i was just telling him
like i think the last three games pretty
much like
mirrored other than my check um
no good first half and we'll come in
probably scoring
third and not scoring fourth or
you know vice versa um not scoring in
third i come try to make a comeback in
the fourth
and uh you know with a team like denver
you can't do that you know they've been
together
um you know for a while they they know
that he has announced it
while he's playing uh
[Music]
like i said last
hey kawhi um how do you view uh this
season obviously you guys had high
expectations
and uh the second part is why was it so
hard for you guys to find a consistent
third score
uh when the the depth on this team was
something praised coming into the year
like i was saying uh you know
we just just couldn't make no shots i
felt like we got some good looks
um you know that's when it comes like to
the team chemistry just know
you know what we should run to get get
uh
the ball in spots are just if someone's
getting doubled or
we're packing the paint um trying to
make other guys make shots
and we got to know what exact spots we
need to be
and you know just got to carry over and
you know just get smarter with the team
you gotta have some more
get smarter that's why you're gonna get
better
okay thank you kawa you're done thank
you